what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation rejoined but my man the
real Aaron Alexander right now because
we're gonna watch One Piece episode two
if you didn't catch her reaction to
episode one that is up here on the
channel really really enjoyed the heck
out of that first episode I change it to
the sweater because I felt like color
scheme wise it kind of feels like one
piece a little bit it does it's like wow
it's very easy oh it's thin too oh my
God you look below me on these guys
highly recommend you can use your promo
code too it's not an ad for them but I
guess it is please go ahead leave a like
on this video that would mean a lot also
subscribe click that notification Bell
we don't really know the pattern of when
these videos will be going up but just
do it so that way you get notified when
episode three is up here on the channel
and as always thank you to all who have
joined our patreon page full-length
Reaction watch along We sync up with
their own copy of One Piece available
for a super sexy rejects we also covers
several shows exclusively over there the
reaction highlights and watch along this
included some anime over there we did
not watch the anime of one piece so this
is all fresh experience for us and it
has been very very enjoyable thus far
and thank you again to prep for having
to set it down these highlights let's
get to it
[Music]
you want trouble
you just found it
little boy Luffy racially ambiguous
Luffy
I can fix it interesting how there's no
like opening credits
yeah right the animes are notorious for
that no two are the same
there's a reason they call devil fruits
oh so there's other people who've had
Devil's fruits who are out there
you know this kid looks like a younger
version of the person who plays gravic
in secret oh my God totally I see it
when will you be back
we're not coming back what rutro she
said that's so apathetically I told you
I need an absolute silence I know I know
it's just that 3D
dude me too and can you please give me
some quiet and some space
I don't even need to stretch for that
one it's not cool
before he left he gave him his hat
that's important to me did you knock it
off I'm trying to take a nap oh I'm
sorry were we interrupting your beauty
sleep
now he's like a weighted blanket a neck
pillow sleeping mask the whole shebang
AC
[Laughter]
ID
ah she's good she's good at what she
does isn't this supposed to be cold
inside a safe it's knowledge this is a
map to the Grand line I'd take the gold
over knowledge any day hahaha
a shortcut past the knowledge
but the gold nugget is by the knowledge
[Laughter]
thin strip of land that circles the glow
it's called the red line it's banned
across the middle is the grand line a
treacherous stretch of ocean with bigger
islands and if you fold that poke a
pencil through it it becomes a wormhole
yeah
the Marines
wow great shooting
sleeping gas
red sleeping gas
swallow it no no way I know a lot of
women who can do that trick you know
what I mean Luffy can take pipes circus
performers
clever I like it
put on a t-shirt I'm so glad this show
is enjoyable it sucks when you commit to
a show it's not a joyful
anime things are going to be mad it took
200 episodes to get to the point let's
get so much damn it we've lost
safe place a lot of these like
interesting angles with the handheldness
that really follow the motion of the
performers yeah
[Music]
oh yes
prisoners having to be pretend to be
audience
it's all wrong Spotlight was late you
completely missed my entrance that guy
looks so familiar oh my God that's a
different Agents of Shield
you're the clown guy
um buggy buggy the Clown
buggy
the genius Jester wow you have a lot of
names
everyone knows who you are
[Music]
okay go bring up the nose sensitive
about his nose I've been scheming for
months
steal that map from old ax hand only to
find out that I was upstaged
by three little nobodies nose buddies
I'm Monkey D Luffy and I will be king of
the Pirates
now that's
wow this is disorienting as hell feels
like a Rob Zombie movie
I can't reward them with that man I
suppose I'll have to offer them a pound
of Flesh Instead This guy's kind of
frustrating what if
I give you a new freak for your crew
I'm gonna offer up Luffy
with his little stretchy powers
hey
[Music]
that was messed up ah dang left their
ass
are they on land
oh my God the set is crazy
wow why would you stop silent Runners
what did you do to their town you
destroyed everything
everything
I let him keep their hands
relax you're being dramatic okay so he
is a sadistic man oh yeah of course
classic clowns
I'm gonna have a chat with my
stretchy New Pal his nose has um
follicles what is it well his nose
doesn't look like some attachment it
looks like it's a real look like
deformity thing yeah yeah it has pores
on it there you go yeah of course they
wouldn't have gotten away in the first
place if my useless son had been able to
prevent their escape do you think the
sun might become a good guy at some
point not with that haircut nearly
enlisted just this morning
sir you think so sounds gonna be good
I'm not sure it could go either way huh
saw a town or what was left of one after
Bucky destroyed it I mean when he tried
to run off and leave us for dead I know
your type but there's nothing to gain
you're out it says the wandering Bounty
Hunter oh we are setting up character
arcs here you have a lock pick I have
four lock picks clowns only found three
oh sheesh
oh that is cruel hey give me back my hat
I used to know a pirate that wore a hat
just like this Ginger three scars left
eye we serve together oh the pirate crew
did he kill him
until he betrayed me
he wanted to keep my star from shining
too brightly young of the Hat
don't talk about him that way finally
getting to the truth
stretch him until he breaks
don't they say in prison I'm warning you
it's
Bucky
[Applause]
there he is there's all this body horror
element to this
[Music]
whoa he punched his head off
I did not see that's coming yo he
punched his head off hi what ah CGI head
and he's alive you have something else
in common what the hell he had one of
the devil's these fruit oh shoot the
chop chop fruit
always
put myself
back together again
whoa it's like the detachable kit it's
detachable kid yeah TDK oh
oh yep
oh no
okay all right that was pretty cool
because I was like ah this guy's kind of
getting on my nerves he's a little
Annoying like he's supposed to be yeah
now I'm like okay now he's a real threat
yeah
I've been thinking about you for years
but how you killed my brother
oh followed us for weeks through the
swamplands
does he not recall you cut off his head
you stuffed it in a bag all for a few
buried okay that does sound like me
let's see if you can keep your head
it's cool they really put the actor on
that yeah
pick that look we both know you don't
but being a marine until I've ever
wanted and I want to believe you but
it's not out
for a guy makes father makes a choice
for himself but it just gets stuck here
how long have you been working with a
pirate to attack this base I was held
captive by a pirate named alvido so he
saved me
don't say his name Lucy ah damn it
you're rat immediately ratted him out
could have made up the name
any name could have said lofi you could
have said lofty waffy son and why didn't
you tell anyone about this I was worried
they wouldn't let me enlist
telling the truth is a core value of the
Marines you could have just slid the
chair with your hands had to be extra
with it can't be a marine unless you're
dramatic do you owe him any Allegiance
Hearts should face Justice
dude and we'll find him together
that's conflicting that sucks
immediately rants him out I'll act so
like freaking terrified every step he
takes every move he makes
I thought the [__] was supposed to
be popular oh he's gonna kick some ass
kick some booty come on Luffy put a fist
in his ass
okay
you wanna talk like a man you better be
ready to back it up lucky man
you're lucky I don't slit his throat you
can spill a drink on me and I'll let it
slide but don't you ever
threaten my friends
[Music]
oh I love this
oh nice Steve's actual superpower you
ever see that Trope before yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right here we go
nice creative as hell
[Music]
dude's got style great fight love this
nice man for pirates that don't resort
to violence this is awesome
only when absolutely necessary I love
the presence of These Guys these guys
are awesome what a dope crew where's
Luffy
oh nice shot
I was a really good upside down reveal
because it looked like he might have
been underwater like yeah it's like have
a dip underwater already it's kind of
confusing so it puts you in the state of
mind he's in that was really well done
don't bother it's seawater all those
wonderful powers rendered useless from a
few splashes see water's a weakness I
guess so see water is his crib tonight
is it that way for all people who use
or is it just a kind of water it is I
really want to know if the water is the
weakness you said seawater specifically
yeah imagine if he drinks water I'm sure
he's fine I will find one piece
and then everyone will know my name
and they'll love me you just want
acceptance
poor Arthur Fleck Chase is gonna grind
you up and make banded sausage they're
nowhere you can hide you really think
anyone is coming for you this guy looks
very familiar
same yeah it's a tavier Arbor them
what the hell yeah the city Beast Sea
Beast
love me a good Sea Beast
how inconvenient is that he's a pirate
who obviously Travels by sea yeah and
his he's always surrounded by his
weakness
shanks
this is Shanks have a
a power oh no okay but he can work with
the CPS
we see it oh damn holy [__] that's a
face that is awesome
oh my God that's scary those red eyes oh
my god
[Music]
get lost
oh he does have a power yeah
oh excellent what a cool design yeah
right I wonder if that's what looks in
the anime I wonder if it's gonna come
back into play later on probably you
know just one and done an animal like
that
oh my God
it's my fault
oh does he bleed out from this I'm just
glad that you're okay
wow you don't look like you're in pain
at all dude yeah he's a man man men
don't feel pain I would be like I regret
it saving your ass immediately
I really don't fear death do you no just
don't fear you
nice tempting as it sounds I'm not
sticking around got somewhere else to be
didn't used to think so
but Luffy changed that don't tell me you
actually believe in him I don't need to
he believes in himself rubs off
and one more thing
don't turn around
[Music]
kind of works like a boomerang in a way
oh
God
my hat mapper the Hat mapper the Hat
oh wow just let them take the map huh he
won't get away with it you want a piece
of me
cool fascinating
oh my God what the hell how do you kill
a guy like that I mean I think you if
you just like drown him if you capture
if bag is head you can at least trap him
guys
it's kind of wild what a Whimsical last
scenario to be in right looks really
good though yeah great ass effects
great effects African dump sea water on
me and I'll let it slide
but don't miss my friends but don't you
ever threaten my friends yup yup or my
hat
[Music]
oh
clap that head what the hell
job
[Applause]
Cannon this is an anime
no no not the Hat how could you
not me the crates yeah
trap him nice that makes sense
it's cool it's a fun game
bastard
what have you done to me that's
identifice
3D
I can't wait for Zorro to call out his
power right oh let's move we are new
captors what
aren't you
I'm a different kind of pirate yep
yep look at him
even they're feeling their heroism as
well hero pirate the men and women of
this base have not failed the Marines
but their leadership has
we can take their ships
their weapons and even their lives but
we cannot win
if we do not take away their dreams
oh [__] personally leading a mission to
hunt down the Pirates Who attack this
base and I am taking this Squadron of
new Cadets with me you want to start
with the new cadets for
justice for the Marines
for Sparta okay now now I really think
he's gonna have a different turn the sun
yeah I don't think he's gonna turn to
help Luffy I think he's gonna turn in
his own interest s
you needed more than we do
what do you guys eat
let me take any food he eats Maps
[Laughter]
some maps and metal maybe just a snack
yeah
none for my friends
just I'm a hungriest I was I was held
captive underwater thank you all
for your hospitality and the food and
the drink
we'll savor it as long as we can and
with lucky rude that should be about
three hours interesting how his he's not
just mirroring him his his life is
really playing out like a pattern that
truly emulates us hmm he's a hero pirate
inspired by the best I miss you most of
all no faith you were right shanks
back when you wouldn't let me join your
crew oh this is when he gets the Hat I'm
gonna be a pirate Captain I'm gonna find
the one piece and become king of the
Pirates
in that case
oh I'm invested
[Laughter]
and I want you to take it I want you to
meet him again one day as an adult
[Music]
you can give it back to me only after
you become a great pirate I'll be our
promise oh oh I guess one day they will
reunite yeah 1 000 live action episodes
from now
14 years that was really sweet now
growing to a Latino boy
with the power of this hat I will
develop an accent
[Music]
almost
finished oh she's helping hmm what's her
name again
her name is daughter of guy from the
beginning
Shanks always said that is the path to
what you want seems too easy then you're
on the wrong path what
[Laughter]
gotta take the hard route that's what
makes it worth it next
next the ground line
I like this guy
if you have ulterior motives girl
a grinder
a little
oh she's communicating you little spy
hello Spy Girl
she's been communicating that's crazy
it's me
you can tell them I have the map what no
Bluetooth Trader
[Music]
oh
you lady
can't trust her damn damn damn let's
look up her name before we talk at all
what's that girls well I'll look it up
while you're talking what did you think
of the episode I thought it was a lot of
fun I liked it
and I liked it whatever you're gonna say
until I was gonna say no I don't think I
was gonna say as much as the first
episode I don't know because I think now
we're finally into the adventure and I
think
even though this is like a 40 plus
minute episode it felt like an episode
of a an anime like it felt like
a piece a chapter in a show but I also
have the episodic kind of feel like a
villain of the week kind of thing with
uh with Bugsy here yeah yeah
um but yeah I thought it was a lot of
fun I like getting to see them Bond a
little bit more learn a bit a little bit
more about Luffy's past and
his powers
I will say the
at first I wasn't as interested in the
the Marine stuff but now we see all the
pieces coming together I'm like oh where
is this heading and yeah I'm starting to
really Vibe with this crew you know like
Zorro cool as a cucumber always her name
is Nami Nami I thought so I thought her
name was Nami uh but yeah I really like
the the way that it was shot too oh yeah
I would keep telling Luffy we could just
call them the funky no I don't think no
one's called him monkey I think he's
only referred to himself as monkeys he's
way easier to remember Monkey D you're
gonna call Monkey D yeah Monkey D Monkey
D
uh so yeah Monkey D he's continues to be
charismatic I'm not gonna call Monkey D
Luffy is yeah you know I think
the show has a lot of heart so far in
addition to being exciting and this wash
buckling Adventure like you can tell
that this is something that's full of
heart and even though I've only seen
these two episodes I can tell that it
has a spirit of anime and this is
probably why a lot of people love it
because like dang this show has so much
hurt and even towards the end where you
see uh the relationship between Shanks
and Luffy and how he finally got his hat
and like the sacrifice that he did to
save Luffy like the the relationship and
how
important that guy is to our lead our
main character yeah and it makes me like
dang I really want to see like what's
going to happen between all these
characters how are these lines going to
converge
and yeah who I really want him to get to
the Grand line because like this kid has
so much heart he believes in himself and
you see the impact of this kid's energy
and how it affects the people around him
because he is so positive and yet so
powerful but isn't like egotistical
about it he's just a good person
and yeah I'm thoroughly enjoying this
um I don't know
how far down the line the stuff with
with Shanks this is something from the
beginning is
is this something that's you know
revealed towards the end because you
know how animes are like 22 minutes long
so and they take like forever to reveal
information so I don't know but um yeah
I liked it I'm not getting the
impression though that this feel this
like to me off of course
constant reminder we haven't
seen the anime it doesn't get I don't
get the impression it's like I I'll
watch other adaptations and stuff and I
really get the impression of this and I
don't get and I don't feel this when I
watch it that I'm watching something
that feels like it's been overly
condensed or that oh wow this needs more
breathing room or they're rushing this
you know like I don't have any of those
opinions about it uh I yeah I like the
first episode more there are things
about this and of course you continue on
the journey you expand upon that make me
like characters like the what this what
this did was make me like the main
characters significantly more even
though I already like them a lot
um I just that feeling has now been
enhanced and I agree with you about the
Marine quality too of like okay yeah
this is much more interesting I like the
Dilemma that it puts
that kid that kid the bow is his name I
don't know his name here with the pink
here I don't know yeah I don't know any
of these names look familiar to you is
it alvita no maybe click on him let's
click on it and we got the IMDb fold up
here nope yeah
what is that Kobe it's Kobe it's Kobe
right yeah yeah it's Kobe yep it is Kobe
yes
I remember doing the Kobe
but um yeah that part wasn't as
interesting because every time they got
to that no nobody is an evil dead rise
yeah I know you haven't seen that that's
right
couldn't piece it together
um okay so yeah uh I like the Dilemma
that it puts Kobe in
because
um
it I think there could be a debate that
happens there of like oh is this
something that you know as I can see the
reaction that someone might have of like
you snitched too early damn you
um but they've established the character
well enough that it's he's such a
frightened dude yeah that is he's just
gonna be
he naturally
he's go uh it makes sense that the pat
that how he got pushed into this corner
you know what I mean like it makes
complete sense to me that that he would
actually unveil that and it does make
for an interesting conflict of The
Journey he might go on because you could
see him going down like paths that do
cause more resistance and put him more
into not quite antagonists but an
obstacle that our Trio has to fight
against you know or could be the path
where he's he ends up you know becoming
so disillusioned by the Marines uh
Conquest I hope that's the path that
goes downwards like this is not what all
what I thought it was going to be and
then decides to help out
either way I think the performer is
doing a really good job because if the
performer wasn't so good I wouldn't have
been I wouldn't have bought that as much
I might have been a little bit annoyed
by the choice yeah you feel you feel bad
for the guy you know and he's in a
compromising position and he's just
afraid he's trying to make it through
and I imagine he joined the Marines
because in spite of all this fear that
he has inside of him he wants to do the
right thing he wants to yeah someone who
who is courageous and you know maybe
he's on the wrong side of things right
now but I hope for the development of
him that he gets that courageousness
inside of him you know and what I like
to or what this episode established
really well
when you compare it to Something Like
Pirates of the Caribbean which is you
know like oh the Pirates there's the the
the the the the the criminals
but you never really get the sensitivity
of the bad guys yeah you know like they
have like bad pirates in there who are
going up against other Pirates
and but you still they still make the
pirate life like they it hones in so
much on the Fantastical side of the
Pirates and the pirates only really seem
to be an issue for like other pirates in
that franchise you know what I mean
where here would I like what they did
with buggy I got kind of like things
that I liked about bugging and things
that didn't what I like that they did
with buggy was was like him and his crew
and and the way they were torturing
this town how they wrecked their whole
town and then they were enslaving the
people
they really showed the truly Sinister
villainous side of pirates so it's not
just also show showcasing
that hey you know like our band of
Misfits are pirates and the seasons and
pirate life glorious like yeah there's
the fun side of it too the fantasy side
of that but they're also showing us now
there really is like a really messed up
side too so I love that they included
that
um and I of course I I love the the
power set of buggy and I I'm ex I wonder
if every villain we encounter with
superpower is all going to be Devil's
fruit oh maybe yeah yeah some type of
Link there
what
I and maybe it is like oh it's an
accurate depiction of
um of what buggy is like in the anime or
something like maybe it is I didn't
ultimately feel
like when you when you do the setup of
what buggy looks like and and like clown
pirate
it went the performance like it's weird
where my conflict comes in is I feel
like the actor who played buggy did a
good job with the material like he
completely serviced it
but I didn't feel like there was
anything TR that
it was exactly the the path that you
would expect based off of oh yeah clown
pirate guy I didn't really feel like
there was anything that unique to it
um specifically his portrayal
not the way you portrayed it but the
depiction of of what this character is
that I I felt like there could have been
something that was a little bit more
fresh about it so he so he actually came
down to being like kind of a frustrating
thing for me to watch a little Annoying
and not super entertaining or even scary
you know and I could have used that for
how much Focus as there was on him
I think it's funny because I remember uh
saying earlier on I was like oh it's not
the performance isn't bothering me
because I'm used to watching this actor
which I now know his name is Jeff Ward
uh and I think that
as the episode continued I became
not conflicted but I held two feelings
at the same time one was like I enjoy
watching the soccer perform in this
goofy role because I've liked him in
other things but the same hand watching
the character itself I think that
and Grant I don't have the anime to
compare against
that it could have he didn't come across
as threatening to me I was never like
afraid or thought this guy was like
crazy or anything I mean he obviously he
was crazy but I'm never like whoa this
guy's freaking nuts I never felt
threatened by him and I think maybe part
of that was the performance as well
um
yeah I just I thought the effects on him
were really cool don't get me wrong I
thought that was that stuff was awesome
but maybe like a little bit more
unhinged slash threatening like when he
was telling them to like laugh or like
you know don't laugh like I didn't get
the sense that
outside of having these guys have powers
that his Aura and of itself was
something that was threatening or scary
yeah that's a good way to put it yeah
you said it much better than me yeah I
think like the power should make him
scary the guys should make him scary and
then the powers are the the icing on top
of the fact that he's scary yeah you
know I think if they would have utilized
or lean into
the the clown aspect of him more and
then how that power thing being enhanced
on the the clown thing I think that
would have worked a lot better so like
maybe this guy was miscast I mean I like
the actor but yeah we'll see what they
go what they do with him
um but yeah I think ultimately that's
what I walked away feeling I thought the
fights are really cool the powers were
really dope you know and especially like
because I could easily have turned into
like ridiculous like dumb goofy
territory but I I don't know if it's the
fact that the effects were good or they
the story and characters were good or
the fact that
I don't know I just think all of it
together worked when it easily could
have gone into like this is Goofy dumb
territory like maybe the knowledge that
it's based on the anime maybe helps that
a little bit but yeah overall the that
fight scene really worked for me yeah
loud hyper sensitive
really just insecure
clown yeah like I feel like I've seen
this like a billion times yeah and it
was this little it was a little it was a
little it was only annoying because it
was so much of the episode you know and
I liked what it did for our other
characters though you know
um like it spoke volumes to me when
uh uh monkey D's hat
got stabbed and I really felt that I was
like [__]
[__] it's good because the show did such
a great job on emphasizing
Yeah by illustrating that whenever this
guy's usually in a chipper mood or in a
a a a ponderous or eager mood and
time he gets serious is when you mess
with the hat or his friends
that was established after like they
really made it clear like he this mood
switches when you mess with his hat
and and how much that meets him and the
show's been doing such a good job at
showing us like where it comes from and
you don't really know yet what the
history is but clearly he has a much
such an emotional attachment I'm
attached to Monkey D so when the Hat got
stabbed I was like oh I was like I've
never felt that with a an item
like just getting struck good like that
it's like an animal okay you know like
something like that and he punctured it
you know and they put so much emphasis
too that's like an old hat you know and
I'm like oh damn so I thought they they
added such great weight with that and I
guess sea water does that is the
weakness as if through swallowing or it
seems like it's just dipping him yeah
yeah just putting him in it weakens him
um and maybe that's the way forever
because he because it seemed like he
really knew that the yeah he said like
don't bother it's uh seawater and
and for buggy to just know that and the
way he kind of threw that line out there
would mean that buggy would also be
um prone to being vulnerable to that as
well yeah yeah yeah because he
recognized as soon as he stretched oh
he's he's bitten the same type of fruit
that I have so by then wouldn't know
what his weakness is which is
interesting because it makes me the more
we watch it that makes me more curious
about the lore behind this world like
what is the deal with these fruits like
where is Shanks and his his people you
know what is going on with with Zorro in
his history and what is this Grand line
which Granite we'll find out eventually
whether it's the end of the season or
400 episodes from now do you think
there's going to be a romance with
Zorro I I got the that that chemistry
that that butting heads kind of
chemistry from those two so well I feel
like Nami you're supposed to she's
supposed to have that duplicitous
quality to her like I don't know which
side is she on but I think ultimate
she's gonna be on the good side yeah
yeah especially toward that thing at the
end when they're using their snail
Bluetooth
maybe maybe it's not as bad as it looks
maybe that's just the Cliffhanger they
left us on I mean she's
she has to be communicating with that
one guy which guy
the guy the the head of the [__]
um gang of the Marines oh you think
she's with working with the Marines GARP
was the only one
remember at the end of episode one he's
the one who talked on the snail phone
and then we heard the incoming we
couldn't hear who was on the other end
oh and then and then when she was making
the sounds with it that was it was the
exact same sounds so I think the
implication is that she's the one
communicating with with the head of the
Marines oh okay she was a little traitor
a little traitor girl okay I could see
that yeah
but why but why though because why would
she why would she bother to steal it it
doesn't yeah it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make sense I can see it but
it's not line enough the math I mean I
guess that it might be a mislead because
she keeps saying how much she hates
Pirates I feel like it's a myth mislead
but I mean we don't know how she feels
about Marines I mean she did kind of
take some of them down so
I don't know if she has more at play
than just that
um but no everything's good and I like
the way how you're seeing Zorro starting
uh lighting up too you know uh but yeah
everything's great right now all right
well six more episodes to go we don't
know when episode three will be coming
out I got working on Aaron's stupid
schedule
with this other job I got nine to five I
got nine to five is not a consistent
nine to five I can work with a
consistent nine to five it's a really
you would be here at 6 p.m and then we
would figure it out my job loves
consistency
alrighty guys thanks for being here
and we'll catch you all soon peace out
reject Nation
[Music]